Hagamos algunos problemas del orden de operaciones
y vamos a comenzar con lo siguiente.
Vamos a iniciar haciendo el 1b y tenemos que
es lo siguiente,
tenemos que el 1b es igual a 2 mas 7 por 11
menos 12 entre 3 y recuerda que el orden prioritario
van a ser siempre tus paréntesis, así que
vamos a ver cómo sería.
Aquí no tenemos paréntesis, pero de mi lado
derecho voy a poner el orden en el que van,
siempre comenzamos con paréntesis, seguido
de los exponentes, luego el siguiente orden
será la multiplicación y la división, seguido
de la suma y la resta.
En esta expresión no tenemos paréntesis,
así que ¿cómo vamos a comenzar?
Y sería importante que siempre recordaras este orden para abordar tus distintos problemas.
Así que aquí la prioridad sería, no tenemos
paréntesis, no hay exponentes, así que vamos
a comenzar con la multiplicación y la división
y estos dos pueden ser equivalentes,
así que podemos primero  hacer la multiplicación
antes que cualquier suma o resta
o nuestra división, antes que cualquier suma o resta.
Y el problema 1b es exactamente equivalente
a esto, simplemente vamos a estar reforzando
la anotación y voy a ir realizando la multiplicación
y división antes de hacer mi suma y resta.
Así que 7 por 11 es 77, luego 12 entre 3
es igual a 4 y el resto del problema es hacer
lo siguiente, 2 más 77 menos 4 y desde aquí
todo es sumas y restas y solo vamos a ir de
izquierda a derecha, así que 2 más 77 es
79 y 79 menos 4 será igual a 75.
Así que el resultado del 1b es igual a 75.
Ahora pasemos al siguiente, hagamos el 1d.
Y este problema resulta ser el más espeluznante
de aquí, por lo que dice lo siguiente,
2 por 3 más 2 menos 1, cerramos paréntesis
y todo esto sobre...
todo esto sobre 4 menos 6 más 2
menos 3 menos 5 y cerramos el paréntesis,
así que veamos cómo podemos ir
simplificando todo esto un poco.
Vamos a empezar con los paréntesis
pues ocupan la prioridad,
y aquí 2 menos 1 es igual a 1, luego de nuestro lado derecho, 3 menos 5 es igual a -2 ó 2 negativo
y luego por acá estos paréntesis, 6 más 2 es igual a 8  y luego realizando como los segundos paréntesis
de aquí arriba, 3 más 1 que quedó de
esos paréntesis, sería igual a 4.
Entonces déjame reescribirlo en color
amarillo por aquí abajo,
sería 2 por esta expresión que es 4, 2 por 4,
esto de aquí es 4
y todo esto sobre 4 menos 8 es igual a -4, entonces
todo esto queda igual a -4 y luego menos -2,
así que ahora sigamos simplificando todo
esto, 2 por 4 es 8 y esto va a ser igual a
-2 por menos, es igual a más 2, entonces
8 sobre -4 es igual a -2, se preserva el signo
negativo y aquí este se cancela y nos quedaría
-2 más 2, el resultado de este espeluznante...
en este espeluznante...
inciso, nos queda igual a 0.
ahora, pasemos a los siguientes, pero antes
de eso déjame limpiar un poco por aquí para
que podamos seguir...
voy a quitar solo este espacio...
déjame quitarlos y este pequeño 0 que nos
quedó por acá para no confundirnos...
Entonces pasando a nuestros siguientes ejercicios,
hagamos el 2b, el cual nos dice lo siguiente.
2b dice que tenemos "2y" cuadrada...
"2y" cuadrada donde "x" es igual a 1,
que en realidad no es importante pues no tenemos
ninguna "x" y que "y" es igual a 5,
sí, el 5 de la "y" sin nos importa puesto que es 2 por "y" cuadrada, sustituirlo sería 2 por 5 al cuadrado.
Aquí como tú puedes observar, yo ya
puse unos paréntesis
y en realidad es lo mismo que si tuviéramos 2 por 5 al cuadrado sin ponerlos,
yo me adelanté para poderlos leer
un poco mejor y como sabemos tenemos que empezar
con lo de nuestro paréntesis o que es lo
mismo que empezáramos con los exponentes,
en realidad no afectan en nada que hayamos
puesto esto y 5 al cuadrado es 25
y al multiplicarlo por 2 el resultado es 50.
Entonces en nuestro ejercicio 2b, el resultado
es 50... 50.
Ahora pasemos al ejercicio 2d y el ejercicio
2d, ¿qué nos dice?
nos dice que tenemos "y" cuadrada menos "x"
y todo esto al cuadrado, donde "x" es igual
a 2 y "y" es igual a 1.
Y si nosotros sustituimos esto,
podemos ver que en "y" ponemos el 1, entonces sería 1
al cuadrado menos "x" cuadrada,
perdón, menos "x" que sería 2 y todo esto al cuadrado...
todo esto al cuadrado...
Entonces 1 al cuadrado es igual a 1, menos 2...
1 menos 2, nos va a quedar 1 negativo y eso
lo elevamos al cuadrado, -1 al cuadrado,
que al hacerlo nos va a quedar igual a 1, pues
menos por menos es más y 1 por 1 es 1.
Entonces el resultado de nuestro ejercicio
2d es igual a 1.
Y ahora pasemos a nuestro ejercicio 3b.
En estos ejercicios, como podrás darte cuenta,
también nos ponen ciertas variables, entonces
tenemos lo siguiente.
Tenemos "4x" y todo esto sobre "9x"cuadrada...
ah no, perdón, ese no es el 3b, estaba escribiendo
otro ejercicio...
El 3b, lo que nos va a decir es que tenemos,
"z" cuadrada sobre "x" más "y" más "x" cuadrada
sobre "x" menos "y", donde las variables
"x" es igual a 1, "y" es igual a -2 y "z" es igual a 4.
Entonces ahora si sustituimos estos valores
en nuestras ecuaciones, en nuestra ecuación,
tendríamos lo siguiente, sería 4 al cuadrado,
luego "x" que es igual a 1, más "y" que es
igual a -2, más "x"al cuadrado que es 1 al
cuadrado, sobre "x" menos "y" que sería 1
menos -2...
1 menos -2.
¿Y a qué va ser igual a este...?
¿A qué va a ser igual esto?
Tenemos que 4 al cuadrado es igual a 16, 1 más -2,
es lo mismo que tuviéramos -1
como resultado más 1 al cuadrado es 1 sobre 1 menos -2, menos por menos se convierte en más,
nos queda 3, entonces tenemos 16 sobre -1 más 1/3,
al seguir haciendo nuestras operaciones,
esto es igual a -16, se preserva el signo
menos, más 1/3.
Ahora, si quisiéramos hacer esta suma, tendríamos
que tenerlo en fracciones, entonces podemos
tener un común denominador y a la hora de
convertir el 16 en tercios, tendríamos que
multiplicar 16 por 3 es 48, al dividir 48
sobre 3, sobre -3 se preserva y nos queda
-16 más 1/3, ahora sí, -48 más 1, sería
igual a -47, el resultado total de nuestro
inciso 3b sería -47/3... -47/3...
Y vamos a lo siguiente, hagamos el ejercicio 3d.
¿Y el ejercicio 3d qué nos dice?
Tenemos "x" cuadrada menos "z" cuadrada
sobre "x" por "z" menos "2x" por "z" menos "x" y creo que si estoy escribiendo el correcto ¿verdad?
Entonces "x" es igual a -1 y "z" igual a 3,
entonces si sustituimos los valores de nuestras
variables en la ecuación, tendríamos -1
al cuadrado menos 3 al cuadrado sobre "x"
por "z", sería -1 por 3...
-1 por 3...
menos 2 por "x" que "x" es -1...
por 2 = -1 y "z" menos "x" que sería 3 menos -1...
menos -1... en realidad siempre que
tengamos menos por menos
pues podría ser un poco más sencillo
que ya escribieras un signo positivo.
Y bueno, 1 al cuadrado ¿qué nos da? 1 por
1 es 1 y menos por menos es más, entonces
esto nos queda 1 menos 3 al cuadrado es 9
y entonces 1 menos 9 es igual a 8 negativo ó -8.
Ahora vamos con el denominador, -3 por 1 es igual a -3 y siguiendo el orden de nuestras operaciones,
tendríamos que empezar con los paréntesis y aquí sería lo mismo que tener 3 más 1,
este paréntesis se convierte en 4 y luego al hacer la operación tendríamos -3 menos 2 por -1
es igual a más 2 por 4, que sería 8 y este menos con este menos se cancelan y entonces tenemos -8...
tenemos -8 sobre -3 más 8, -3 más 8 sería
lo mismo que al hacer la operación es igual a 5.
Entonces este resultado es igual a -8/5.
Y bien, creo que ya no tenemos mucho espacio
para continuar y voy a volver a quitar esto
para no confundirnos y vamos a lo siguiente.
Ahora llegaremos a algo interesante, el problema 4
le insertaremos paréntesis a la expresión
para poderlas hacer como una verdadera ecuación
y va a resultar fascinante.
El inciso 4b nos dice que tenemos 12
sobre 4 más 10 menos 3 por 3 más 7 igual a 11.
Ahora veremos qué pasa, si simplemente vamos
siguiendo el orden tradicional para realizar
operaciones y bien lo haré poco a poco en
mi cabeza para irlo experimentando...
¿y... si es éste el 4b verdad? sí...
es que no quiero volverme a equivocar,
así que vamos a hacerlo.
Siguiendo el orden empezaríamos con la
división que 12 entre 4 es 3
y luego la multiplicación que 3 por 3 es igual a 9 y luego ahora vamos a tener sumas y restas,
3 más 10 es igual a 13 menos 9 es igual
a 4 más 7 es igual a 11,
ah, entonces sí luce bien, creo que
llegamos a un resultado coherente.
Así que solo hay que seguir el orden regular
de las operaciones y esto en realidad ya es
una ecuación correcta por lo que si hacemos
12 entre 4, como habíamos dicho más 10
menos 3 por 3 más 7, entonces nos sale un buen
resultado, pero deja confirmo, sería 3 más 10
menos 9 más 7 y 3 más 10 por este lado
es 13 menos 9, 13 menos 9 esto es igual a 4...
13 menos 9 es igual a 4 y luego 4 más 7,
en efecto, esto es igual a 11 por lo que no
está tan mal, pues entonces aquí no será
necesario poner paréntesis porque esto ya
es una expresión correcta, sino simplemente
hay que seguir el orden de las operaciones
y queda listo, pero dichos paréntesis
lo que nos están haciendo es ayudarnos a leerlo
un poco más fácil, pero bueno, ahora vamos
a trabajar con el siguiente ejercicio, 4d.
Tenemos 12 menos 8 menos 4 por 5 igual a -8.
Si seguimos simplemente el orden, aquí la
multiplicación, 4 por 5 es 20, luego 12 menos
8 es igual a 4 y 4 menos 20 no nos estará
dando el resultado igual a -8, esto nos daría
-16, entonces aquí...
perdón, borre el 8, aquí es -8.
En este caso, sí sería necesario ir poniendo
paréntesis para llegar al resultado que queremos,
entonces déjame lo intento de dos formas
a ver con cual llegamos.
Digamos que tenemos 12 menos, este paréntesis
8 menos 4 por 5.
Si seguimos el orden de las operaciones, 8
menos 4, empezamos con los paréntesis,
8 menos 4 es igual a 4 y luego al hacer la
multiplicación, 4 por 5...
4 por 5 es igual a 20 y 12 menos 8, en efecto,
llegaríamos al resultado.
A ver, vamos a repetirlo, lo que hice fue
poner paréntesis por aquí y 8 menos 4 es
igual a 4 y luego 4 por 5 es igual a 20, entonces
nos quedaría 12 menos 4 por 5, 4 por 5 es 20,
al poner estos paréntesis y 12 menos 20 es igual a -8, pudimos poner también aquí
paréntesis para ir preservando el orden de
las operaciones pero de todos modos nos va
a salir el resultado.
Y en efecto, esto es igual a -8.
Nos vemos.